ich freue mich sehr heute hier immer
viele der 100 zentrum zu sein ich sage
ganz offen ein schöner termin für einen
bundesminister aber auch eine wichtige
einrichtung für uns es ist nicht so wie
es aussieht das ist kein streichelzoo
sondern es ist eine ganz ganz wichtige
einrichtung für die ausbildung von
hunden ein weltweit anerkanntes institut
eine weltweit anerkannte einrichtung mit
über 2.200 registrierten kunden 1600
diener ausgebildet worden sind und die
hier auch ganz ganz wichtige ausbildung
erleben um dann auch im einsatz für
schutz und hilfe zu sorgen gemeinsam mit
unseren soldaten
[Musik]
heute habe ich die freude gehabt zwei
labore zu übergeben beziehungsweise zu
kaufen die dann auch in weiterer folge
im einsatz stehen wir wünschen den
beiden aber natürlich auch dem gesamten
militär und dem zentrum alles alles gute
und für soldaten krieg
[Musik]